how to get the most out of your doctor's
visit we caught up with former veteran
time magazine health journalist janice m
horowitz with important questions you
should ask your doctor and even what to
look for while you're in the waiting
room
[Music]
the first thing you do when you sit in a
doctor's office is scan the office
if you see pens and mugs and
pads emblazoned with the name of a drug
you know that that doctor has probably
been hit with very eager sales rep or
has gone to a conference horowitz warns
that if that doctor prescribes you that
drug it's important to ask how many
people were in the studies that got that
drug approved if you are like the people
in those studies and if there is an
older drug that might perform just as
well as the new one because doctors can
anticipate side effects much better from
an older drug than they can a new one
also never go on a life drug ones that
you'll be taking for years to treat
things such as cholesterol diabetes or
high blood pressure based on just one
test make several and lastly get a
second perspective not a second opinion
she explains
for
her shoulder go to an orthopedist go to
an
physiatrist they specialize in muscles
and the reason is those different
doctors in different fields have
different training and they have
different guidelines they will bring a
wholly different perspective you'll have
more information and you'll get better
care
janice says if you're feeling rushed
during your doctor's appointment feel
free to ask if you can continue with
another paying appointment at a later
date christian
today cars trucks and suvs are safer
than ever before but a new kind of crash
test is showing there may be room for
improvement the insurance institute for
highway safety says because vehicles are
now bigger crashes can be more powerful
particularly